construct a circle inscribing the
triangle so this would be a circle
that's inside this triangle where each
of the sides of the triangle are tangent
to the circle and one way to or the one
the probably the easiest way to think
about it is the center of that circle is
going to be at the in center of the
triangle now what is the in center of
the triangle the in center of the
triangle is the intersection of the
angle bisectors so if I were to make a
line that perfectly splits an angle in -
so I'm a balling it right over here this
would be an angle bisector but to be a
little bit more precise about angle
bisectors I could actually use a compass
so let me make this a little bit smaller
and what I can do is I could put this
the center of the circle on one of the
sides of this angle right over here now
let me get another circle and I want to
I want to make it the same size so let
me Center it there I want to make it the
exact same size and now let me put it on
the other one on the other side of this
angle I'll put it right over here I want
to put it so that the center of the
circle is on the other side of the angle
and the circle itself or the vertex sits
on the circle itself and what this does
is I can now look at the intersection of
this point the vertex and this point and
that's going to be an angle bisector or
the angle bisector so let me go I'm
going to go through there and I'm going
to go through there now let me move
these circles over to to here so I can
take the angle bisector of this side as
well so I can put this one over here and
I could put this one see I want to be on
the side of the angle and I want to go
right through
I want the circle to go right through
the vertex and let me add another
straight edge here so I want to go
through this point and I want to bisect
the angle so I want to bisect the angle
go right through the other point of
intersection of these two circles now
let me get rid of one of these let me
get rid of one of these two circles I
don't need it that anymore and let me
use this one to actually construct the
circle inscribing the triangle so I'm
going
put it at the center right over there
actually this one's already pretty close
in terms of dimensions and with this
tool you don't have to be 100% precise
it has some margin for error it has some
margin for error and so let's just go
with this this actually should be
touching but this has some margin for
error let's see if this was good enough
it was